the Joe Rogan experience did you watch
the Kobe loose man fight yeah I was a
little bit of it little bit not the
holding how would you think I thought I
was crazy crazy I thought I was crazy
that was a while I like what you said
you know even though like if you don't
go we talk like that most guys that talk
like that act like him can't fight he
can't fight he could find he tricks you
he does he tricks anything he sucks
he's wearing a cheap suit he's caring
around Donald Trump Jr's book is wearing
a manga hat reading that reading that
[ __ ] but I mean he's lucky I give up
I give it up to that guy for a lot of
reasons first of all he was his back was
against the wall the UFC was telling him
they're gonna cut him after this fight
with Demian Maia they don't like his
style they think he's boring
they literally told that to him yeah so
he goes in the ring after the fight
cause Brazilians a bunch of filthy hands
says a bunch of crazy [ __ ]
and the next thing you know he's got
this [ __ ] character oh yeah for
children we were making fun of his suit
[Laughter]
and next thing you know he's one of the
most popular guys in the [ __ ] sport
from talking [ __ ] and that was only
three fights ago man there's a massive
adjustment yeah it's crazy smart yeah it
is you know in a day you know if people
ask me well you feel like he came out
and said that it was like a stick you
know I was like oh sure whatever it is I
just told people like it's him
you know I mean like it's not me why
bother let the guy let the guy waters
like he's digging his own grave let's go
dig it you know I mean he got living it
now you know like now I got living it
like I think that the firepower of the
axe over deed why did you laugh when you
found out that he outed himself I was
like because it's a storyline you don't
see this WWE guys running around like
yeah no they should keep their storyline
until they go out and we can how did it
first me out it at first me and Brendan
Schaub out it at first yeah the whole
story latino/latina
I would text you and be like be honest
II like Joe Rogan
guess what I hate you and that's it as
all I'll leave it at that's it and when
it comes back up I don't know what
you're joggin is allowed I'll stop
making lunch all good all you smoke weed
that space he's looking just regular
grass guys you heard here first
he's smoking regular grass guys oh
that's hilarious we haven't had a guy
that put on our character like that
before
he's the first yeah yeah you shot in a
little bit yeah Chael Sonnen a little
bit you know he kind of put on a little
bit of an act like that but Colby took
it to a whole new level I mean the suits
and he's adjusted it over the years cuz
if you go back and look at the beginning
of it he used to wear nice suits he was
wearing like a sweet a very nice
tailored suit laughing expensive now
he's wearing the cheapest [ __ ] that he
could buy like blue and orange he's
wearing he's on purpose you know he's
doing on purpose he's wearing cheap
suits it's [ __ ] hilarious man
it's hilarious it's terrible and it was
a good goddamn fight it was a good fight
it was real close fight got 50k it was
three and three on three judges
scorecards are on two judges scorecards
they had it three and one so three
rounds to us man on one judges score
three rounds to Colby on another
treasure scorecard yeah it was that
goddamn close and 2 & 2 with the last
judge this is another example a lot of
being crazed and crazy but this is
another example why we should have more
judges yeah you should have more than
three judges it's quite a judge Olympic
Olympic don't know I think be gala I
think they have eight and then they take
the they take like the top whether they
take whatever score is matched like not
five whatever and then they back then
they better make sense that makes sense
eights a good number nine would be a
good number because none would be like a
tiebreaker yeah you know like if you if
you had five one or four one wave the
way I feel like three is ridiculous like
why you only have three you know the
judges suck already so why do you only
have three people that suck and
[Applause]